we eat some of these popular foods every
day and we never wondered where they
came from but you will be surprised to
learn that they really look weird in
nature make sure you stay tuned until
the end to know why cashews can be
dangerous if you love food as much as we
do don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you what popular foods look
like before they're harvested peanuts we
didn't even wonder how peanuts grew we
just thought that it magically appeared
on earth when it was sent from God
almonds and walnuts grow on trees but
unlike them peanuts actually grow in the
ground here's what penis look like in
the field you can see Stewart plants
that grow up to 18 inches tall it's
quite unusual because it flowers above
the ground while it fruits below the
ground
the peanuts do not grow from the roots
but the pegs of the plants this is the
reason why peanuts are not actually nuts
but legumes like peas and lentils it
suddenly gives us a reason to eat more
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches and
pretend that it's a salad hey guys we
are so excited to announce we are
producing our own original content head
over to the trendy for the best DIYs
fashion tips makeup hacks and so much
more we are sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section you love to
hear from you see you there
cacao it's weird to think that we ate so
much chocolate but we never thought
about where it came from they say that
money doesn't grow on trees but we don't
care as long as chocolate does unlike
most fruit trees it sprouts flowers and
seeds pots from its trunk and main
branches and it produces fruits during
all the year you can see blossoms
unripened fruits and fully mature seed
pods at the same time up to 10% of the
blossoms will produce a fully mature
fruit this is how a healthy cacao tree
can yield up to 2,000 pods a year when
we think that chocolate is actually made
from fruits we think that it's a healthy
choice okay all the Edit sugar ruins
everything but we can easily forget
about that quinoa it is now one of the
most popular choices when someone wants
to
eat something healthy but how can you
say that you pay attention to everything
that you eat when you don't even know
how it grows the protein-packed seed is
actually harvested from tall green
plants the plant sprouts are slowly
growing at first but they eventually
shoot to 3 feet the part of the quinoa
plant that we usually eat is the seed
the leaves of the plants are also edible
so it would be a good idea to try them
in a salad what is impressive about this
plant is that it can be cultivated in
high-risk areas as it is tolerant to
cold salt wind and frost now we
understand why it's so popular dates if
you think that dates grow on a calendar
you probably didn't understand that
right anyway you probably didn't care
about edible dates because they are the
least popular dry fruits at the grocery
store we want to give them some love and
this is why I will tell you some fun
facts about them people are really
motivated when it comes to harvesting
this unwelcome fruit because it actually
grows at the top of very high palm trees
up to 75 feet high dates are found in
big clusters just underneath the palms
fronds and it just looks weird we hope
that you are not afraid of heights
because it will take a lot of courage to
climb there sesame seeds we always see
sesame seeds on bagels and hamburger
buns so we have to admit that we once
thought it was just part of the bread
when we were kids but now we obviously
all know that it grows in nature
actually it shouldn't be so surprising
because there is the word seed in the
name the sesame plant native to Asia and
East Africa grows fruits the long pod is
then dried and this is when it starts to
open revealing the seeds inside the
plant is then shaken to release the
seeds however we are still wondering
about one thing how these sesame seeds
even stay in place on hamburger buns
there must be a sesame glue or something
cranberries you probably think that you
already know how this fruit grows after
all you've always seen it growing in
water right actually it's only one part
of the process
technically cranberries just grow on
vines like strawberries all they need is
a special combination of soil and water
properties the reason why they grow
underwater is to protect them from cold
temperature during winter in the spring
the field is strained and the
cranberries will be back underwater
again when the time comes to harvest
them they just have to knock the berries
off the vines and they will start
floating this is just the proof that you
shouldn't only look at one picture to
know the full story vanilla most of us
didn't even think that vanilla could
grow we first thought it was just a
little taste of heaven added in our
favorite ice cream or our birthday cake
but did you know that vanilla actually
comes from an orchid so in nature it
looks like a really pretty flower the
vine can grow up to 30 feet long and the
vanilla plant folia is the only plant
used for industrial food production but
the part that we usually eat the pod
looks more like a green bean they are
picked before they are ripe and plunged
in hot water and then dried for up to
six months this is how we end up with
this black thing we didn't expect
vanilla to be a pod that is so old
pineapples contrary to popular beliefs
pineapples don't grow into the sea and
no sponge lives in them and they don't
grow on trees either
they are right in the middle as they
grow out of the ground from a leaky
plant we think that it just looks like
someone dropped a fruit on a poor little
plant but a healthy pineapple plant can
have leaves up to five feet long the
fruit grows out the top of the central
stem and is actually the result of
dozens of individual fruit producing
flowers that are fused into a single
fruit we just have a weird feeling every
time we look at a field full of
pineapple plants cinnamon if we asked
you to guess what cinnamon looks like we
think that it would take you a lot of
time to get the right answer that's
because it doesn't look like any other
plant on this list but more like a
simple tree actually it comes from the
inner layer of bark derived from
evergreen trees the farmers shaved the
outer bark of the trees and then the
inner bark which is the cinnamon layer
they then dry it out for use this is
when it curls up in quills which are
then crushed into a spice powder cut
into sticks now we think that you can
recognize it cashews when we first took
a look at cashews we were
wondering how they actually grow if they
ever grow at all it turns out that this
nut grows from a faucet that looks like
a red apple the cashew itself is
actually the real fruit the fake fruit
is also edible and is often made into
beverages or Jam but we all know that
nothing is more popular than the cashew
itself but you shouldn't eat them in
nature because their shells contain an
acid that causes allergies and reactions
similar to poison ivy have you ever
wondered how any other popular fruit
grows don't be shy to share your
thoughts in the comment section down
below we love to hear what you think and
that's it for what popular foods look
like before they're harvested for more
stories like this make sure you watch 10
foods you'll never buy again knowing how
they are made thanks for watching
[Music]